Let's jump into learning more SQL.
We're going to focus on the WHERE clause
and the ORDER BY clause in this video.
there we go. All right, our
objectives for today, we're
gonna continue to write SQL
queries and we're gonna understand
the usage of the following
clauses, WHERE and ORDER BY.
So we can do a variety of different
things in that WHERE clause. Now
remember, WHERE clause is a
conditional statement. It says that
every record must meet these
conditions or condition in order to be
turned in the output. So one thing
that we can do is called a wildcard
search, which uses the SQL-like
keyword that basically searches for
partial data values. So for
example, if by chance I did not
understand, you know, I wanted just
to show all of the employees with the
last name that started with the
letter L. I could do something that
you can see down here, right? Like
L and then the percentage sign.
So we could do something like
that, where this is going to return
every last name that begins with
the letter L and has any number
of characters after the letter
L. So any last name that starts
with the letter L, it's going
to be returned to me, my output.
Similarly, but a little bit different,
we can do something like a single
character, so an underscore. When
we want to look at, when we want to
use underscores, what underscores do
is they say, okay, if we know their
last name starts with the letter L,
and we know that it is four total
characters, then I would put three
keywords after the letter L. So if
their last name was Lane, L-A-N-E,
then I would put three characters
after the letter L, and Lane would
appear, okay? So sometimes you're like,
you know what? I know that they
have this many number of characters,
and that it starts with the letter
L, I can specify that search a little
bit differently than with the
percentage sign that just looks for any
number of characters. So let's do
a couple of examples. I'm going to
go over to Beekeeper, so I encourage
you to have that launched as well.
Let's just do a quick select star
from our guest. We're going to end
that. We're going to make sure that we
are capitalizing our select and from
and that we end it with a semicolon.
We go ahead and press run here.
All right, so now I get all
of my guests, all of their
information is appearing. So
let's just go ahead and say, all
right, in my where clause, so
we know that semicolons signify
the end of a query. We always
end it with a semicolon.
But I'm going to add a where
clause onto this. I'm going to say,
you know what, wear a last name
like, and I want to say last name
like that starts with that letter
L and has a percentage sign
after it. So any number of
characters return, I'm going to put a
comment up here, so two dashes,
return all guest information if their
last name starts with L. Okay,
so let's go ahead and run this.
All right, so when I do this, I can
see that I have all these last names.
Lambert, Logan, Lee, Lopez,
Lark, Lyons, Lewis, Lara, Lopez,
all these different last names
and they all start with the
letter L and they have a variety
of different number of characters
after them. So that's how I
would do a wild card search if
I didn't know the entirety of
what I was looking for but I
knew a portion of it. I could
say you know what I know that I
just want to return all last
names to start with the letter L.
So we could do something like
that. The next thing we could do
So I just, I copied all
of it, did control C or
command C based on what
you're using. And I'm going
to say control V. I'm going
to paste it down below.
But I'm going to say return
all guest information if their
last name starts with L and
is four total characters.
Okay.
So I want to only have last names
returned to me to start with
the letter L and have exactly four
characters after it. So I'm going
to do an underscore, so L
underscore, underscore, underscore.
This is going to say return their
last name if it starts with the letter
L and has three characters after
that L, so four total characters.
So when I run this, we now see
that the last names that start with
the letter L have three characters
after the L are returning to me. So
really cool tool you can use when
you write SQL queries is this like.
Now, I encourage you, if you know
the exact value of what you're
looking for, so say you're like, I
don't need to do a search here. I
know that I want to return everybody
with the last name equal to Lark.
Then make sure that you say last name
equal to and you say Lark because
the equal to is much more efficient
than the like, and it's best
practice. So if you know exactly
what you're looking for, then just
say equal to Lark. But if you don't
and the prompt reads something
like, return everybody with the last
name starts with the letter r or
whatever it may be then then use
the like command but if you know
the exact value you're looking for
use the equal to sign um so just
keep that in mind but there we have
the wild card search that we use
in our where clause um the where
clause can also do things like we
can use an in which can simplify our
query so So let's go ahead and run
this query, and I'm going to say
that I want to return all ski
levels, or I want to return all
employees whose ski level is intermediate
or advanced. So let's go ahead
and do this. I'm going to create a
new query sheet, and I want to
return all guests, or all employees,
who are intermediate or advanced skiers.
So I'm going to say select
star from employee, okay?
And I don't like how it
does those quotation marks
throughout, so I'm just
going to delete those.
So select star from employee,
and now I can see I have their ski
level. But I only want to see employees
where their ski level is
equal to intermediate,
okay?
So if I just run this, then
it's only going to return skiers
who are intermediate okay so
we want intermediate though or
and now this is where it becomes
a little bit more complicated
we can't just say or advanced
because this or basically says
um the this is the end of this
ski level equal to intermediate
we're saying or something else
so it basically gets rid of
any connection to that ski level
okay that is one this is one
condition that it must meet and the or
starts another condition
that it must meet.
So therefore I must say or
ski level equal to advanced.
Okay so now I'm going
to go ahead and run this
and now I can see that ski level is
equal to intermediate or advanced.
If I try to run it without the
ski level repeated if I just try
and run this it's going to say an
expression of a non-boolean type
was specified in the context. So
it's going to throw us an error.
So just make sure that you remember
that. And that seems like a
really good test question, if
you know what I mean. All right.
Another thing to keep in mind
here is we can do that in
a keyword that I just
referenced. So I could answer
this in two different ways.
I could write it like this,
or I could write, I'm going to
copy this, or I could write it
like this. And instead of having
to type out ski level equal to
that again. I can say ski level
in and then just provide a list
of values that ski level could
be equal to to be included in the
output. So I'm going to say ski
level in, a left parenthesis,
intermediate with single quotation
marks around it, and advanced.
So basically what this comma
does is this is like a mini or
if you want to think about
that right, right? Ski level in
intermediate or advanced. So now
when I run this second query,
I receive the first output as the
query up above, right? So these
are the two different ways to write
the same query and receive the
same output, but the in is a little
bit more, a little bit easier
to do. So we're, when we say ski
level in, we're just saying ski
level must be equal to intermediate
or advanced. I could add one on
here too and I would just if I
wanted to add another value it needed
to be equal to to be returned in
my output. I could say equal to
beginner or I could add beginner
to the end and when I do that then
beginner is all beginner skiers
are also included in my output.
But to stay consistent I just want
intermediate or advanced but I just
wanted to show you it's really easy
to add additional values to this
list of values included here with
this in keyword okay all right awesome
so that's a really helpful tool as
we're learning different SQL techniques
we also can do something like
the between operator in my where
clause so we're just learning a bunch
of different things that we can use
in my where clause and in my where
clause if I I wanted to say, show
me everybody whose age is equal to
19, or who's equal to 19, 20, or 21.
So if I wanted to write that query,
so let's see, show me all guests
who are 19, 20, or 21, I could do
something like this, and I could
say select star from guest, let's
see here, where age is greater
than or equal to 19. So if I wrote
that, this is saying that everybody
returned in my output must have
an age equal to or greater than
19. I press run, and now you can
see here everybody's age is going
to be greater than or equal to 19.
Now, if we wanted, I'm going
to add something in here quick.
I'm going to add in my order
by. Now, I haven't learned about
our order by quite yet, but
I'll teach you really quick.
Order by age ascending means that
I am going to order the output
by the age field ascending. okay
so from a to z if you want to think
of it that way or from smallest
to largest so this is a way that
i can check that there's no 18
year olds 15 year olds included in
my output right the youngest age
or the smallest age here included
in my output is 19 and i can
check that by adding the order by
which comes after the where clause
and allows me to double check that
what my query is outputting to me
is correct. So now let's add on
to this. This is only restricting
it that they are 19 and older.
But instead I want it
to be 19, 20, or 21.
So what I could do next, I could say
where age is greater than or equal
to 19 and age is less than or equal
to 21. Okay, so now what this is
saying is it's saying, okay, age
must be greater than or equal to 19.
So that requirement has to be
fulfilled. and the age must be less
than or equal to 21 so effectively
it's saying the age must be 19 20
or 21 so now i run this and i can
see here that every record here
is returning all guests who are 19
20 and 21 okay there's my 21 year
olds right so just keep that in
mind that's one way i can write
the the query. This is the beauty
of SQL queries. You can generally
write them in multiple different
ways. But another way that I can
do this is instead of having to say
age greater than equal to 19 and
age less than equal to 21, I can
say we're age between 19 and 21.
So now when I run this, this
between is inclusive, meaning
it's going to include my 19
year old. It's going to include
the 20 year old in my output.
So now when I run that query,
I see that I'm getting exactly
the output from this query up
above, right? I'm getting the
exact same output. It's just
another way of writing a query.
And that's really powerful.
Oftentimes when you're asked SQL
queries and interviews, whether it be
internship interviews, job interviews,
you are going to be asked, can
you write this query in one way? And
then they may say, can you write it
in another way? They want to see
your ability to problem solve your
knowledge of SQL queries. So that's
just to keep that in mind. All right.
So there you go. There we
have it. That is my between,
which is so, the between
operator is so helpful.
All right.
Okay. Then finally on here, we
talked a lot about where. We're going
to continue talking about where.
We're going to practice a lot with
the where clause. but then finally
my order by my order by is sorts
the query results it sorts the output
okay so we say order by the column
name and then we can say ascending
or descending so let's go ahead
we can do it two different ways
we can um up here we say order by
last name descending okay so that's
going to be uh last names basically
we'll start with z and uh go to a
and the z will be at the top and
A will be at the bottom and then
similarly we can do the same thing
here and instead of referring
directly to employee last name we can
refer using the pointer as a textbook
talks about and the pointer basically
says that the first name here
is the first column in my select
statement and the employee last name
is my second column in the select
statement. So we would say order
by two and this pointer basically
points to that select clause and
says order by the second column in
the select clause. I generally do
this manner, this first one, because
if for any reason the order of my
select clause did change, I don't
want it to mess up my order by. So
I normally say exactly what column
I am sorting by using that column's
name in my order by. All right,
so let's create another query sheet
up here and let's just say show
all guest info and sort by youngest
to oldest, okay? So I'm going to
do select star, you guessed it,
pop quiz, when I'm showing all the
guest information, select star from
guest, and I'm going to say sort by
youngest to oldest. I'm going to
say order by age descending, okay?
So I'm going to say
order by age descending.
And now when I run this,
I can see here that my,
oh, from youngest to
oldest. Uh-oh, rut row.
Order by age descending is
oldest to youngest. If I want it
from youngest to oldest, I need
to say ascending. There we go.
And now we have it. age is my
youngest is elijah strickland and
griffin walker and luke ruse and
ariel duncan all of these two
-year-olds they are my youngest in
my database okay but if i wanted
to say you know what show me
their first name last name and age
okay i'm going to make this a
little bit cleaner here my select
clause so now i'm just showing the
first name last name and age of
all of them sorted from a
youngest to oldest the other thing
with the order by clause is us
send ascending is actually default.
So if I run this, it's
still going to sort it by
ascending. So this query and
this query are the same, okay?
So order by age ascending,
that is just default. So if you
just say order by age, it will
do ascending. You can also
still type out ascending. I
tend to still type it out,
but you could absolutely still
just leave it by default.
But instead, if I want to say
sort by oldest to youngest,
I would just change the order
by age into descending, okay?
And now what we see here is
we see Marie Craig, Samara,
Jordan, Quinn, Sterling, Brian,
Annalie. They are starting from
the oldest and going to the
youngest based upon their age.
Similarly here, if I wanted to use
that pointer that I talked about
and point to the column instead, I
would say order by three descending.
And that is going to do the
same thing. It's just order
by age descending. Okay. So
I hope that that's helpful
to you in getting used to
the order by. Again, order
by, we just say what column
do we want to sort by?
And then do we sort ascending,
descending?
Order by is really helpful.
So thanks, everybody, for tuning
into this video. Take care.